[Musique]
françoise bureau vous êtes étudiant
depuis combien de temps je prépare une
licence de lettres modernes à la
sorbonne depuis deux ans et au logement
actuellement je suis à proximité du
quartier latin chez une logeuse assez
empoisonnant qui surveille mes allers
venues qui entre dans ma chambre à
n'importe quel moment mais celle en
grenier vous êtes étudiant depuis
combien de temps
c'est la première année que je suis
étudiant en lettres et où le gvt ou
lactel je lâche mes parents mais une
maroc deux pièces avec mon petit frère
qui était celle du temps il faut bien le
dire
c'est difficile pour travailler à dispo
dans ces étudiants depuis combien de
temps
si la première année de lettres que je
fais une logique propre et j'habite dans
un foyer de jeunes filles quartier latin
à la lance vous êtes étudiant depuis
combien de temps
depuis un an je crois par saint cloud
lettres et ou loger vous actuellement
chez mes parents que sera alors pour
vous la chambre devant
chambre indépendante où je puisse
recevoir des visites où je puisse
rentrer alors que je veux sans être
surveillés surtout du calme une chambre
qui serait situé dans le quartier latin
près de la faculté pour les
bibliothèques le restaurant et surtout
pour les la faculté rapidement et puis
d'autre part une chambre qui serait
assez grande de loyat s'est réduit avec
l'eau l'électricité et le chauffage
mais surtout c'est la proximité de la
faculté qui est importante
une chambre dans paris ou même dans la
proche banlieue avec les commodités de
transport et surtout le calme et si vite
et de l'étranger pendant tout mais
évidemment ce serait d'avoir à tout prix
une chambre pour pouvoir travailler en
liberté indépendance et toutes les
facilités ne suis pas exigeant d'abord
le grand problème seul prix avoir une
chambre dans le loyer sera très peu cher
vivre à deux dans une chambre se fait à
la longue concessions réciproques mais
c'est quelquefois difficile aussi bien
psychologiquement que
pour un tas de détails matériels alors
j'aimerais la même solution avec une
chambre seul ou bien encore une chambre
particulière n'importe où pas trop loin
du quartier latin quand même est assez
élevé c'est à dire que
j'aimerais une chambre par exemple 4e ou
5e étage quant à amy bonjour nicole tu
saches une enquête soulagement étudiants
à le logement mais si tu veux et de
faire visiter ma chambre
alors tout d'abord tu as le balcon avec
une vue imprenable depuis notre dame
jusqu'à l'arc de triomphe
ensuite la cuisine fonctionnelle avec
ses meubles de rangement le lavabo ira
salle de bain ils cros extraordinaire
une chambre de bonne
le chauffe eau enfin aussi le lit qui
est le meuble principal problème à peu
près toute la place il dira que la
chambre se trouve autour du ce qui fait
qu'il prend beaucoup de place pour
éviter de travail suis obligé de mettre
la machine sur un cube ce cube s'est
autrefois le cabinet de toilette de la
bonne qui habitait ici
et puis pour finir l'armoire dans
laquelle on casse tout mais forcément
n'est pas bibliothèque tu viennes
province mais depuis combien de temps et
tu à paris et comment tu fais pour
trouver cette chambre
eh bien j'ai fait mes études
effectivement avallon ensuite je suis
venu à paris où je suis en propédeutique
à la faculté des lettres
et pourquoi tu as l'appareil avait
sûrement faculté plus près le bia depuis
toujours j'ai rêvé de venir habiter
paris parce que je pense que paris c'est
vraiment le point de rencontre de la
jeunesse mais en arrivant à paris le
problème du mal logement s'est posée
comment l'as-tu résolu est là et bien je
fais comme n'importe quel voyageur en
arrivant j'étais à l'hôtel
malheureusement l'argent pendant mes
parents et celui que je gagne en donnant
des cours et insuffisants pour payer les
30 mille francs des trente mille francs
par mois de l'hôtel alors j'ai dit aux
copains aux services les bureaux du
logement et pendant un mois environ
j'ai essayé de trouver une chambre mais
cette qu'on proposait étaient trop
éloignées du quartier latin ou alors
elle cédé trop cher et j'ai trouvé je
finis par trouver cette chambre dans des
relations que penses tu de cette chambre
présente elle des inconvénients
elle présente quelques inconvénients par
exemple il y à la suivait sur les toits
de paris qui rentre à la fois par le
balcon et vue par la fissure du mur
ensuite elle et moi je vous fais c'est à
dire j'ai un petit réchaud électrique
qui marche mais qu'il faut au caire le
l'hiver et l'été elle est trop fou fait
parce que c'est le toits de zinc qui est
vraiment brûlant alors l'été je suis
obligé de sortir de travail et sera au
prix de 28 lits soit à la bibliothèque
quand il ya de la place mais si tu as
choisi cette chambre
c'est tout de même parce qu'elle
présentait quelques avantages oui elle
présente l'avantagé d'être dans un
immeuble
c'est à dire qu'on a un contact avec des
gens qui ne sont pas de l'étudiant et
avec ses voisins quels sont tes rapports
et bien ne sont pas un intime mais ils
sont très cordiaux c'est à dire que par
exemple au 21
il ya l'électricien parfois ils m'aident
à me dépanner quand fait un enduit et
que mon courant ou alors au 19 il ya une
famille entière qui habitent là et c'est
agréable de d'avoir une vie de famille
près de soi cas peut-être pu remarquer
d'ailleurs dans le couloir les jouets et
les enfants en somme pour toi la chambre
de bonne de paraître est la solution
idéale donc tu sais idéal c'est pas
encore ça c'est à dire que il faut mener
c'est pas nécessaire que la chambre soit
sous le toit mais je crois qu'il est
important que la chambre se trouve dans
un immeuble avec où tu peux voir des
gens qui ont une autre vie que la tienne
par exemple j'aurais très bien pu
habiter dans une cité étudiante avoir
une belle chambre avec des douches ou au
restaurant universitaire en bas mais
j'ai préféré habiter ici pour ne pas
vivre toujours dans le même milieu et
puis je crois que l'essentiel surtout
c'est d'avoir ça vu ses murs qu'ont
soleil et puis d'être indépendant
[Musique]